por Ahora siguen las huelgas pues ayer
se reunió la dirección de total con
todos los sindicatos y logró un acuerdo
pero con otros sindicato no la cgt que
es el más radical el más a la izquierda
sino con la cfdt y otros menores Que en
total representan a un 56% de los
trabajadores sin embargo aquellos que
son mayoritarios en las refinerías y en
los depósitos son los trabajadores que
están afiliados a cgt por lo tanto ese
acuerdo de ayer de la empresa
estipula un 7% de reajuste de los
salarios más una prima de 3000 a 6000
euros el próximo año sin embargo los
trabajadores de la cgt se levantaron de
las negociaciones y rechazan ese acuerdo
y John hoy en siete sitios han acordado
volver nuevamente a la huelga así que
por ahora sigue un tercio todavía un 30%
de las gasolineras sin combustible en
Francia al menos algún tipo de
combustible y lo que es peor regula
antes de la negociación ayer
sindicatos la cgt los más a la izquierda
fuerza Obrera y otros menores habían
llamado a una gran huelga el próximo
martes interprofesional no solo de la
gente de la energía y los combustibles
sino que también de los funcionarios de
los transportes Así que la situación ese
día martes se prevé bastante complicada
una mala noticia también para el
sindicato cgt ayer un tribunal de la
ciudad de ruán ha rechazado el recurso
que ellos habían presentado contra la
requisición de los trabajadores de los
depósitos es decir obligarlos a trabajar
dice que eso no pone en riesgo el
derecho a huelga en Francia